hi
welcome
to our 2020
to
may meetup pi data meetup in triangle
please allow me to present our first
speaker um proudly dr ann
drillo trilos
dr drills as a postdoc in the personal
lab at duke university
uh originally trained in computer
science and physics and she is now
applying machine learning and
statistical technologies to
real-time analysis of neutral and
behavioral data
and he uh she she is now currently a
schwa foundation fellow for theory in
neuro neuroscience and received a 2021
career awards at the scientific
interface from the
baroques
welcome found
welcome and
thank you
all right let me uh
share my screen
and uh hopefully y'all can see that all
right
um yeah i think okay great thanks thanks
for the introduction and getting to give
a talk here at our
meetup um i will say if anyone wants to
interrupt and ask questions at any point
that's super fine um you know and i'll
try to leave a little bit of time
towards the end also
uh
four questions if you have them
um but yeah so i am at duke university
and i work on computational problems
that are applied to systems neuroscience
so basically i'm interested in how to
create new machine learning methods that
run in real time
to help us more intelligently and more
automatically dissect how the brain
works
and some of what i'll be talking about
today
can be applied to other fields i chose
to move into the field of neuroscience
because
i founded a very
interesting big data high throughput
kind of problem um
and so i've been doing this for the past
four years and the work that i'll be
talking about today uh
was done uh under the supervision of
john pearson and eva naumann who are
both faculty at duke university
all right so the a big problem in
neuroscience um is like a big goal is to
understand things about the brain um and
that's obviously a fairly large goal but
i think increasingly popular uh
able to be potentially solved with a lot
of our new computational resources
so we want to understand things about
how the brain is like wired up how it's
structured and how it functions so how
it's related to behavior
um but so how do we even go about
conducting experiments not just data
analysis that can give us information
about the brain
and one of our goals is you know to do
this in a living animal we want to do
experiments that let us understand
brands of living organisms eventually
living humans as well
while they are engaging in a variety of
behaviors so that we can do that sort of
causal or correlational analysis between
neural activity and behavior and do so
at single neuron resolution so there's
this hypothesis that the
neuron is this uh unit of computation in
our brains although there are plenty of
other things going on up there
but we're going to focus on this idea of
using single neurons and then scaling
them up to thousands and thousands and
maybe a million neurons
and how we can really craft experiments
that allow us to
to understand
these systems
so there's there's been a lot of new
technology to physically enable
experiments that can help us
characterize whole brains
and in particular like advances in
microscopy have let us image really
large portions of the brain
in animals like mice or fruit flies and
basically the whole brain in
things like the larval zebrafish
which is the organism that i am
primarily
going to be talking about today
and then sort of more excitingly
not only can you optically image
basically the entire brain of this
animal you can optically stimulate it
so you can use lasers to also stimulate
individual neurons
which effectively gives us a kind of
read and write access to this system
but this is great but
you know as i'm sure you're well aware
you have a wealth of data but uh
you know that means that you have a lot
of possibilities about what you can look
at and you have this problem of dealing
with a very massive data flow so for
images that we're going to take off the
larval zebrafish
you it can go up to hundreds of
gigabytes per hour um
and it's you know what can we do with
all of this data if we want to actually
test some biological hypothesis
uh during an experiment you can think
about changing one variable at a time
right very classic method and examine
the results
um but if you're dealing with a system
that is scaling up to maybe a hundred
thousand neurons which is what we have
in the zebrafish
um testing one thing at a time is going
to be a really slow and inefficient way
to figure out how the brain is actually
doing computation
so instead we have this idea for
tackling that kind of problem of scaling
experiments up to entire brains
and it's really similar to this i this
this idea of
20 questions this game of 20 questions
and if you haven't played it's really
great for like long card trips
um
so it's easy uh to play this game
suppose that i'm thinking of an object
and it's your job to ask me yes or no
questions to determine what that object
is
so you know if you've played it you know
that even though i could be thinking of
a near infinite set of possibilities
this is a very winnable game for you
because you get to pick each next
question after hearing the answer to the
previous one
so for instance if i were thinking of a
duck you could solve this by asking a
series of questions like is it smaller
than a bread box is it a mammal does it
have webbed feet and so on
but what if instead i forced you to ask
all of your questions at once without
hearing any of the answers to them
you could write down a list of queries
to easily figure out the duck but only
if you sort of knew what i was thinking
about ahead of time
right you'd need potentially millions of
questions to cover every possible object
i might be thinking of much more than
20.
and by analogy you can think about if
you had a really large data set and you
wanted to look for patterns you don't
just choose something you want to find
and then look for it you might instead
do a more sophisticated analysis
and gradually narrow your search based
on the data that you pull out
right so 20 questions if you play it
where you get to pick a new question
after hearing the answer each time it's
very winnable right and so it's this
it's very powerful because we can adapt
our next question or our next query
or or next piece of analysis to the most
up-to-date and new information that we
gathered from the last question
okay so this general concept of an
adaptive experimental design
lets us take advantage of data as we
collect it
so you don't have to do just post-hoc
analyses you can start analyzing
and potentially change your questions as
you gather data
and so
you know what we
have started to do is apply this concept
for neuroscience experiments
and in particular if you would like to
do this kind of
adaptive questioning in the brain you
need some sort of real-time data stream
and real time models to give us an
explanation of the answer that we are
receiving
all right so what do i what do i mean by
talking about real-time models here for
neuroscience experiments
and in general the kinds of experiments
that we're talking about
are
a live organism like i said we're
imaging its brain and we're showing it
something in particular
for in in this case we're going to be
showing it a series of moving gratings
so just a projected picture you could
also think about you know giving it uh
something to listen to or you know
different experimental variables
but basically correlating some sort of
uh stimuli external stimuli and imaging
of the fish while a fish might be doing
something like pretending to swim by
flicking its tail
so it's a general idea of the experiment
where does the modeling fit in and
typically the kinds of experiments that
people are running
can be quite complex
so there are different tools and
different pieces that we would draw from
observing behavior or these stimuli that
i talked about the way that we're
recording mineral activity can change
there may be different ways to record in
the brain and there's a few different
ways to um to manipulate the neural
activity to stimulate the neural
activity right so we have all of these
kinds of things
and models in particular of course are
used to give us this quantitative
description or inference
for whatever system that we're studying
and then they additionally help us
generate new testable hypotheses
so if you're a neuroscience experimenter
and you are doing these kinds of
um
these kinds of experiments
in vivo you are likely constructing some
kind of experimental design
that is drawing from most if not all of
these elements
but in at least in academia
in the lab
when you are implementing these
experiments especially if you have
experiments with real-time constraints
right
these are going to be really lab
specific so built by the graduate
students and are highly specific to one
particular lab with one particular
animal and so on so they're very
difficult to generalize to other labs
and other animals in part because of the
tight integration that's required
between all of these components
so one of the things that we've worked
on over the past couple of years is this
a software platform written in python
called improv
it's a flexible platform designed to
help us engineer these real-time
adaptive experiments
all right and i'll go into more detail
about improv and
later but in general just think of it as
the glue between each of these
components in a very flexible way that
allows us to adapt to what is currently
going on in the brain and potentially
change our experiment as we have that
real-time data stream
um but first i'm just gonna
keep grounding you in this example of a
particular experiment and how we've used
improv in the lab
to allow us to run these real-time
models during an experiment
and so zebrafish like i mentioned
previously are pretty great because you
can image basically their whole brain
when they're about a week old
this is an image that i acquired
in evan almond's lab and it's
artificially colored but basically you
get you know just a
ton of neurons here and this is a static
picture but of course you know they're
all firing at different rates and um you
have this very high throughput data
problem
and in particular one thing that eva's
lab studies
is this optomotor response
um
so the
zebrafish which is right there
is going to see
moving gratings
these black and white stripes here and
the zebrafish is going to want to swim
to align itself
uh with the direction of those moving
gratings right
so optomotor response basically the
zebrafish is going to see things it's
going to do some sort of computation in
the brain that we'd like to take a look
at and then it's going to have a motor
response by flicking its tail so that it
can stay aligned to what it sees as the
visual motion
okay so this is just another schematic
of the exact same thing we've got the
fish under the microscope it's seeing
those gratings and we're imaging its
brain so this here is a video of the
gratings moving under the scope and this
here is a
video of what we see in the brain okay
and
if we wanted to analyze these
this data
in real time we would need to do things
like motion correction and neuron
finding
um we're going to do some spatial
selection of these neurons and extract
their activity so the intensity in these
images
over time
we might also do a deconvolution to look
at neural spikes which is seen as the
the base unit of activity of neurons
okay
um so if we wanted up to the moment
information about the brain we need to
do
all of that for all the neurons we see
and we can't look ahead in time right so
each time we get a new image we need to
immediately process it immediately
update our model um before
we have time to acquire a new image so
this is what i mean by real time we do
all of our processing and model updating
in the time it takes to acquire the next
image
okay
and in general
like i said this can scale up to about
100 gigabytes per hour for imaging um
in practice the work that i've been
doing with eva
is not going to be
that high of a data rate but it still
can be quite high and i'll go into more
detail on some of those data rates as
well
okay so
back to improv which as i said was the
uh
nice
um flexible python focused um
package that we wrote to help us do
these experiments
and the concept behind this uh is
related to the actor model in computer
science where each step in the
experimental pipeline
is an actor so think of an actor on a
stage it's solely responsible for one
job it is not dependent on any other
actors
and so we might have a single actor
called an acquirer actor and its only
job is to take the image from the
microscope and
pass it on right it's his only job
and we might have a different actor that
says
what stimuli am i showing to the fish
and that's its only job
right and so basically if we're able to
parcel out the experiment into these
different actors what we can do is
execute
each step so each little actor has a job
and you can do all of these jobs
concurrently
rather than sequentially
which really helps with execution if
you're trying to pack in all of these
things at once before reading
the next image
okay and so the way this works um with
improv um
we uh
you know
are responsible for
uh instantiating uh each of the actors
which are going to be user defined
inside of a separate process
and then instead of having to transfer
data between actors like and i told you
these these images can be quite large
sometimes and coming through pretty fast
so you don't want to transfer the data
directly
so instead we're going to put this data
into an in-memory shared data store
and
tell whoever else needs to know
a key to say you know this is
where i put the data and if you want to
go look at it here is where it is okay
so these these arrows here in our
original diagram of the experimental
pipeline um are communication
not data flow so more like
execution
order there okay and so here i'm
leveraging
um uh libraries in python that include
the multi-processing library and async
io libraries because again you don't
want to have a blocked
execution
um and uh
importantly um using this um
the particular in memory shared data
store of course you could pop in
different shared data stores if you
wanted but the particular one that we
choose to use is called plasma which is
part of the apache arrow project
so basically this is
like i said in memory so it's quite fast
to access and it is a zero copy read
operation
so if you just needed to look at the
data and use it to update your model but
not modify the data um then you could do
this without copying it
um and and you don't need to copy or
deserialize the data
um and so this obviously makes for
really really efficient
way to handle the large amounts of data
that we have going through
um and this is written in c plus with
python wrappers and i'm not sure if it's
been ported to other languages but um
it's it's it's a great uh
package if you're interested in using it
okay so the way this works
this is the same diagram i showed you
earlier
where each
piece in your experimental pipeline is
an actor
and we wanted to make improv super
user-friendly
so that
many neuroscience labs would be able to
take improv and
adapt it to their particular use case
um so all you need to do to spec your
experiment um we have a configuration
file it's just a yaml file and you say
what are the actors
and you know what package am i supposed
to import these from what class is this
and improv takes care of all of the
instantiation
um and setting up the message passing
that needs to go on between these actors
and and so on
and then the only other bit of
information that you need are basically
what are the
communication connections
that you need right so for instance the
acquire
uh the output of us and here we're using
a custom
multi-output async cue
in python and here you know we want it
to go to
both an image processing actor and a
visualization actor so that we can keep
the experimenter in the loop
right and so you just list out what are
the logical flows here
so and then the class definition that's
all up to the user
but in general there's a particular
flow that we're using here so for this
analysis actor and this is the one that
we're going to focus on we're going to
focus on real-time modeling so this is
what our analysis is going to be
um this is just some pseudo code showing
the analysis actor is going to be a mean
analysis we just want to take our new
data which are our neural activity over
time
and compute a running average
so like i mentioned you're going to need
to get a key
to get the data from the store and here
the get isn't necessarily a copy
operation um
so you're going to get some sort of
estimate of neural activity from the
store you're going to do whatever kind
of computation on it that you want in
this case we're just doing like a mean
for example
and you might you know compute a couple
of different things and put those
results
back into the store
we've supplied something called our
client here which is just the store
interface
which is easy for people to use
and then once you're done with that you
tell the next person down the line where
you put this data right so you get the
data you do something to it and you put
different data back in
and basically what this this kind of
framework allows us to do is this
concurrent execution so if i'm an actor
i'm not blocking anyone else i'm just
waiting for data to exist and then i can
go on and do my operation
so this is super efficient this way
and a search interrupt but i see a hand
raised up
oh sorry i don't
yeah i don't see it sorry i'll i'll do
the job to
to call people's name no worries
and i was wondering if you're doing a
running
running average
where do you set the
number of data points prior to the
current one that that are averaged i i'm
pretty sure you don't want to average
from the beginning of the experiment
you're this is a a running
um average so where
where do you decide
yeah is is that from experience or
experiments or or how was how is that um
interval
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so in general the kinds of um
analyses that we're talking about which
is not usually a running average
are
you start from zero so
you start the experiment with improv and
you start to collect data so the first
data point you take that's your average
the second data point you keep a local
so each actor class has local variables
that you can keep around
that are not associated with the data
store and so you just keep a count of
how much data you have acquired and use
this to update your running
average does that make sense
sorry i can't
mark your mute
yes yes thank you okay sure yeah
um
cool
so
yeah one of the reasons we designed it
this way is that you can both be
flexible with the design of your
experiment but also run super fast super
fast
which is the whole goal here
and if if you look at this figure here
in our little experiment where we have
some sort of pre-processing and model
fitting maybe and some visualization if
you ran all of these tasks sequentially
which is typically done by the time that
you got back around to acquiring a new
image after all of this um you're
delaying your acquisition it's been it's
been too long
um
you know in our
uh with our particular implementation
because we're leveraging this
concurrency
and doing some speed up uh work as well
all tasks can be completed in less time
than it takes to acquire the new image
and so we stay under in this case a
hypothetical 30 hertz
time budget
and equally important
if you look at
basically the gap between acquisition
and for instance processing the image
right you need that gap to stay exactly
the same you can't accumulate a time
delay
and so here even if we have a small time
delay on a particular frame we're able
to catch up and stay locked to
acquisition so real time here just means
that we're staying
as fast as acquisition can take place
um and then
we're also you know fault tolerant by
design
um if for instance your acquisition
actor
uh stopped working all of a sudden you
don't want to be have to shut down your
entire experiment um you want to be able
to keep going and because we've
separated out each of these things into
unique actors if one of them fails
everything else can keep going
uh while you try to resurrect this one
and pop it back in and so you have this
really fault tolerant kind of work um so
that when you can pick it back up
everything keeps working
okay so like i said this is the kind of
design of improv and we've used it in a
lab for these kinds of imaging
experiments in zebrafish
uh so this is just a quick graphical
user interface that we've done with um
pi qt
uh just a sort of proof of concept
where here we're gonna be be
taking images from the microscope and
just displaying them so this is the raw
image
and then immediately we're going to turn
around and process that image
and start to look at something more
sophisticated
which is the what we call functional
typing of neurons and basically it's
just saying
uh which neuron
is sensitive to which kind of stimulus
right
so um we're going to be showing the fish
some stimuli that are denoted here by
color
and this we're going to start with a
backward moving grating so the fish sees
motion going backward and immediately in
its brain right here
you can start to see some neurons
light up colored purple and here we've
colored it purple because it's
responsive to backward motion
we start to show it rightward uh forward
motion and you see different neurons pop
up and start and show that they are
sensitive to this yellow color-coded
motion
and then you keep showing a different
stimuli and gradually um with using sort
of circular averaging you can work out
what kinds of
visual stimuli these neurons are
responsive to okay
um and then i'll go into more detail uh
about this but basically here we can
also like i said concurrently at the
same time
do some uh
gradient descent on a particular kind of
model and simultaneously fit a model
that also tells us basically
what sort of connections can we infer uh
in between these neurons as well
okay so the first thing that i mentioned
what we're able to do is functional
typing we're able to take a look at the
neurons and in real time figure out what
they care about
and we can use this information to
really get a rich picture of how that
individual particular brain is encoding
what it is seeing
and uh like i said we are also doing
some model fitting um here we're using
it's a fairly common model in
neuroscience um it's
what's referred to as a linear
non-linear poisson model and it's just a
model that
is used to look at the different
influences on neural activity
um so the each neuron has some sort of
baseline firing rate a response to
stimulus you know a
knowledge about whether or not it has
been active recently and
its connection to other neurons okay
you don't necessarily need to care about
the exact details here because they're
specific to neuroscience but basically
the log likelihood here
we're going to maximize the log
likelihood
and because this is a convex kind of
problem
we're guaranteed to converge even
fitting online
as opposed to fitting a model offline
which is more traditional
using things like stochastic gradient
descent
and we can do this
in
extremely efficiently
and find good results of our online fit
compared to that of an offline fit which
is when you fit the model with all the
data that you have
okay so moving slightly away from
zebrafish super briefly
um improv in general like i said it's
designed to work with you know any kind
of experiment hopefully
and so here i've replicated an analysis
to
from a different paper here
where
in addition to the
neural imaging just just like i showed
you we're also going to look at
a video in this case from a mouse uh
a video of the mouse's
face
uh and pause
so the mouse is being imaged in its
brain just like the zebrafish was
but we're also recording what it does as
motion output
and we can use an online method of ridge
regression
to learn what features in this image
are predictive of the simultaneously
recorded neural activity
right and so um here x are the
behavioral features in the video and y
are the neural data
and what we find is that our
our regressors that we pick up here
quickly basically converge that we're
able to really quickly learn what they
are and that they are stable during our
experiment so we get a real-time model
of the um basically predicting
what's relevant in the behavioral video
to what's going on in the brain
okay so improv is this foundation um
and it allows us uh to handle real-time
data streams
and use them to refine model parameters
uh online so in real time like i just
showed you with those two examples
but again practically speaking we need
to be able to interface with many
different kinds of tools so i've shown
you um how we work with our specific
experimental partner
for the fish imaging
and what about other programs or other
tools that other experimenters use
right not every uh so so our system is
set up to
not
solve every problem of course
but it's a lightweight scaffolding
approach
that allows you to pop things in and out
to different to different actors
as needed and so this allows us to
incorporate other tools that would
otherwise be hard to incorporate
so batch processing here not every kind
of software tool that people use in
neuroscience works in a streaming mode
in fact that's a lot of our research
trying to
transform these models so that you can
fit them online
but you know you don't necessarily need
to do that what we've done with improv
is
ensure that we're easily able to hook up
to other
uh python packages for instance
that are doing batch processing so they
need to look at maybe a hundred frames
of data before they can do
some processing and give a result
instead of having a result each frame of
data
but we were able to interface with them
we can handle things on different time
scales both a true streaming and a batch
processing time scale
we also looked at making sure that we
could integrate with different control
software so for instance in
uh
you know some
companies that manufacture microscopes
don't like people to mess around with
their code of course you know you can't
touch the internal
of some microscopes and so you can't
necessarily easily
send images via python
but what's really nice is you don't
really have to
you can use improv to monitor sort of
downstream images instead of needing to
get it from the guts of the microscope
we're using also it's not on the slide
but we're using
a zero mq zmq
to also talk between different kinds of
control software for things like labview
matlab and python
um so you know the really nice thing
about python ecosystem and this open
source code in general is that easy
interoper interoperability of many
packages but we are able to to interface
with
more closed systems as well
and then lastly
we we
this actor model kind of framework
allows us to easily integrate with other
tools including tools in different
languages
and i just wanted to show you a quick
example
of integration with julia
so both python and julia if you're not
aware already have packages that are
designed to interface with one another
so there's the python package pi julia
which can compile and execute julia code
from within the python program
and then there's a julia package pie
call to do the reverse
but basically here what you can see is
for a particular actor we have an
example of this in our code base
we might use this julia module
to
call this get mean function which is a
julia piece of code
and
use
the conversion options
so that we're not necessarily copying
data between python and julia
but we are
using a no copy wrapper as long as we're
using numpy
okay and then when we actually so this
is just to set up the function
and when we actually run the function in
a streaming sense
in a streaming set
we can just simply execute the function
as long as it's numpy array which most
of our images are
and immediately get back the result so
the computation itself is done from
julia but everything else remains
agnostic to this and the rest of improv
runs in in python very easily
okay
so that's just a little bit about some
of the interoperability that we've
worked on
uh where
where do real-time models fit in i guess
more um practically
um and
like
i should say you know the online model
fitting that we do
um
you could just acquire all of your data
and then fit a model offline you
definitely could do this
but we find it very important to be able
to
have these online models
so that you can
adapt the experiment to what is
currently going on in the brain and one
of these goals is to be able to
stimulate
neurons like we have like i said we have
read write access
while the animal is active right
and furthermore we don't just want to
stimulate neurons uh sort of randomly
with no prior knowledge we want to use
those real-time models to tell us where
we should be stimulating
and in particular
we want to
learn and then
stimulate neural trajectories so neural
data across time neural trajectories
previously we looked at a kind of static
picture of the brain and we used online
model fitting to lock in a specific
picture right we're just learning the
parameters over time and coming to a
conclusion but now we want to be able to
learn
adapt to and stimulate neural
trajectories again all in real time so
this is going to be slightly more
flexible
and
the important thing to know here
is that we're going to treat this uh
neural activity just as time series data
so neurons are firing and we have that
data over time
but in
organisms like the larval zebrafish
that's a lot of neurons
and each of those neurons you know
hundred thousand
so what we would like to do is instead
of looking at that high dimensional
representation
drop it down to a low dimensional
representation
so the kinds of neural trajectories that
i'm talking about are the
latent dynamics or the lower dimensional
um trajectories here
so rather than
looking at the activity in these three
neural dimensions which is just the raw
neural activity we want to instead
encapsulate it in a model that is lower
dimensional okay
and so what we did
is we built a new method that allows us
to do this in real time
first we
made a new
streaming method for going from those
high dimensional
many individual neurons
down to a low dimensional representation
of that neural activity
and here
there are
existing versions of streaming or
incremental um things like svd to get
down to that lower dimensional
representation but the vectors that they
return can be really variable you can
see it um abruptly flipping or changing
and this is quite hard to then build a
model on top of if your whole basis that
is changing really abruptly across time
so instead we came up with a new method
here
that minimizes the change in the
singular subspace basis between data
points right we want something that's
consistent through time fairly stable
but able to track slight changes in the
subspace
um that we're calling pro svd because
it's a orthogonal procrustes problem
solution
so what's important to know here is that
after only a few seconds of data seen so
after only a few seconds of images
the derivative of these basis vectors in
our low dimensional space has dropped
and we come to a time stable low
dimensional representation of the data
so once we have that data
in this low dimensional space
we're going to want to learn a model
and the model that we're using is a
gaussian mixture model so we have
different tiles here with a mean which
is the black dot and variance which is
the orange
so we're going to want to learn where
the data are and put our mixture of
gaussians to cover the data
and we're also going to learn a
transition matrix
using a hidden markov model
so what we're going to learn instead of
trying to model like really closely
exactly what the data are doing because
the data is kind of noisy we're going to
learn a soft tiling of this space so
we're going to approximate the neural
trajectories
with this kind of model
and this uh model is very flexible you
can
it can be used to capture
basically
changes in transitions so diverging kind
of trajectories
um
and both components of this model the
gmm and the hmm
are fairly easy and fast to compute
so this is just a quick movie showing
how this model
is um
fitting the data
online right so we start from scratch we
start to see data and then we start to
fit this data
and we adjust our fit
constantly throughout the experiment
so these are the node locations and we'd
also learn a graph that basically says
we're going to transition from this node
to this one to this one to this one and
so on right so that's the dynamic the
trajectory portion of this
we applied this model to a number of
different
um
data types in neuroscience um one of
this is electrophysiological data
where here again we start from scratch
we start to look at
this low dimensional neural trajectories
you can see them being traced out in
blue here
and as we see
new ones we can pop in
new tiles that's the orange there
to help us cover the data
and learn predictions for where the data
are going to be next
okay
and this model you can see we're fitting
this across time this is our
predictive probability up here so
we're able to quickly learn the model
fit and the entropy that uh the entropy
in our system drops as well okay so
we're able to do this fairly quickly um
with
uh
and keep up to date with it as we
continue the experiment
we also went ahead and looked at
behavioral data so not just neural data
but also behavioral data
using the same kind of video
from the
mouse that i showed you earlier so
previously we did this online bridge
regression and now we're going to do
this online dimension reduction and look
at the trajectories through this space
and so the data itself are
not as structured as the spiking data i
showed you
but you can still see these trajectories
traced out in blue and the tiles that we
learned to help generate predictions for
motion in this space
and
i'm almost at a time but i wanted to
briefly mention um
running this in that same zebrafish
experiment that i told you about
where the kinds of trajectories that we
see
are associated with the motion of the
grating so when the fish starts to see a
grating move across its face
the neural state space runs out here and
when you turn the grating off it comes
back to the sort of rest location
and we're able to again continually
track what this model is doing
and since we're able to continually
track we can then think about
perturbing
the neural activity so stimulating the
neural activity
as you change this trajectory and start
to design
new ways to
to move in this neural state space
um okay and in the last uh five-ish
minutes or so um but please interrupt
with questions if you have them i'm
going to talk a little bit about
performance boosting so how real time
are we actually going to get actually
going to get um ken
you know the question i actually get
from a lot of people is why are you
using python if you care about real time
um you know can python keep up
and i can confidently tell you that in
every case we've currently looked at the
answer is yes
um
so i previously showed you this kind of
experiment here where we're
benchmarking the image processing we
have to do and getting the neural
activity out
and here we're running it faster we can
run it faster than 30 hertz
and the most of the kinds of data
acquisition systems here are going to be
acquired at 30 hertz or slower
so here we're definitely able to keep up
not a problem
um
more
i think excitingly if you
um
more excitingly this bubble wrap
algorithm i showed you with the neural
trajectories so we're building a model
and we're tracking things across time
we can run that at depending on the
experiment uh rates
much much faster than you can acquire
the data so rates at about hundreds of
hertz all the way up to kilohertz um the
electrical the electrophysiological data
is recorded faster than the imaging data
but i think it's still on the order of
kilohertz
in which case our modeling should be
able to keep up
and then lastly i want to point out that
the predictive aspect of this is what's
particularly important we want to
predict into the future
and we can generate these predictions at
faster than 10 kilohertz
so again faster than you can acquire the
data
which makes these real-time
adaptive designs very possible
and one of the ways that we have been
pushing
these real-time data processing and
real-time model fitting
is obviously through accelerated
computation
and i'm sure some of you are familiar
with them but just in case these are the
ones that we've used that we really like
um so
there are a couple packages that we've
used to offload some of our computations
onto the gpu um so things like kupay
which is a numpy scipy compatible
library
that's intended as sort of a drop in
replacement for numpy
you can also write custom kuda kernels
with it and execute those in python
and then my current favorite is jax
which is
a research project out of google
which is bringing together
auto differentiation if you need to
differentiate through your models for
things like gradient
descent
as well as accelerated linear algebra
and so you get super fast and automatic
um basically automatic model fitting um
and you can compile this code and put on
the gpu and it's quite great it has some
idiosyncrasies um
if you want to discuss them but it's
it's it's
a really good um
way to immediately accelerate your code
without having to actually change much
of it
um you can also of course use different
languages like i already talked
about you know and then pretty easily
interface back to python um for anything
else that is less time sensitive
um
and then uh i thought i'd also mention
python or cython here
which is python but as well as c
um i haven't personally used it but i
know other people in the lab that have
to help speed up their computation
and then you can
you can accelerate via different math
right you can choose different ways to
fit um you can choose different ways to
compute different
you know things like uh celeski
compositions you should make sure that
you know what order c or fortran you're
doing your matrix multiplication in
different approximations and this is
less one size fits all it's going to be
very specific to your model
but don't discount looking a little bit
at the math
if
just switching out a package is not
going to do it for you
okay so i hope i've shown you that um a
really cool application of python in the
neuroscience sphere is is um
improv here which combines this
real-time model fitting and this notion
of adaptive experimental designs to
enable streaming analysis and
basically new experimental designs that
can allow for
stimulation of neural activity in real
time based on what that current brain is
doing in the moment
um
our code is open source here on github
and i'd be happy to get in contact with
anybody who's interested in running
these sort of real-time adaptive
um model fitting
and of course there's been a lot of
really excellent people whose work who
have worked on this as well as um
thank you to the funding sources um and
to you guys i'd be happy to take more
questions
great thank you ann uh you're right on
time
wonderful wonderful uh would uh we do
have uh maybe one or two minutes for
questions uh mark you have questions
uh yes i was wondering if you were going
to
attend sci-pi conference down in austin
so my my schedule right now is a little
bit terrible because i'm um interviewing
for faculty positions um so i haven't i
have not made plans to um but i think i
would like to be involved in this
community yeah
or or anybody on your team it doesn't
have to be you but
i think that there's
there's probably going to be a lot of
interest in in that community
to hear about to hear about improv and
bubble wrap and
that kind of stuff
yeah i will bring it up at our next team
meeting tomorrow um thanks yeah
okay um okay can i jump in i have a
actually a number of questions i think i
can get through them uh pretty quickly
first of all his name isn't on this last
side but i'll be darned if i'm not
seeing the hand of jeff beck in uh
bubble wrap does he have anything to do
with that no i mean i know who that is
but he did not oh okay okay oh he was
just somebody who was always into uh
hidden markov models and uh gaussian
mesh yeah it's a very honestly it's a
very um
not common but a lot of
it it works really well in a lot of
different kinds of neural time series
data yeah okay cool uh next one um
there's promise of doing a genuinely
adaptive experiment but if i paid
attention
well you didn't actually show us one
right you didn't actually show us an
adaptive experiment where literally the
results of the model fitting was used to
guide the next you know experimental
stimulus that was being presented or
something like you are very correct um i
didn't i
the only adaptive experiments that we're
currently doing which is unpublished
work um and i don't have i didn't bring
it up today
are in that zebrafish experiment what
we're doing is we are fitting a model to
um
like learn the relationship between all
the different neurons that we see
and we are using this to select the next
visual stimulus to display to the fish
so we do have an example use case for
this sort of adaptive
actual closed loop kind of design
but yes you're right and nothing i
showed was actually closed up yet okay
um
then speed is one issue but
the even maybe more critical issue is uh
synchronization and timing and you need
sub millisecond precision for this and a
master clock that's calibrated across
devices and i'm is that is that a
problem you guys you claim to have
solved um with a python based framework
that's
to be intended to be as flexible and as
interoperable as as you want it to be
yeah the the the monitor clock says 37
milliseconds in you know the the spike
acquisition clock says 38 milliseconds i
mean right you know that that kind of
thing yeah no no it's it is an issue
it's it's my it's it's an issue that we
haven't solved on the e-fizz kind of
recording so that's a much faster rate
we do have so within improv we do have
uh synchronization if you need it for
the data
but
primarily this is gonna be on one or two
different machines um with just simple
time stamping for information flow um
and what was the other thing oh the
other thing is we
uh in practice most of these imaging
experiments um don't care on the order
of
five milliseconds
um
delay you know or jitter uncertainty in
the timing but you're talking about
spikes
i'm not i'm not sure i'm not sure that
that's really a fair statement
for the spikes definitely we would care
for the calcium imaging you're looking
already at a convolved signal um you're
not able to distinguish necessarily five
milliseconds all right i saw i saw a lot
of spikes in this presentation um but
okay that last question last but that's
fine um but you know a lot of other
experimental software packages will use
real-time operating systems and kind of
really mandate this uh for the reasoning
of synchronicity but um
frankly i always wondered if it was
really necessary maybe it's not uh last
question
it's not so much
okay last question starts with a joke
you've probably heard from software
engineering what's the great thing about
standards
there's so many to choose from um and
there's so many experimental control
software control packages out there and
i'm wondering what's what's the strategy
are you guys just
better than the you know literally maybe
a thousand other ones do you have
anybody else using it besides the
nominee yet or is the idea just to be
have a really good package that's just
going to be better i mean is there a
like why
why not you i mean
so we have are these people who really
need this
that couldn't use something else that
was already out there right yeah
long question no uh so yeah there's um
there's at least one other lab at duke
that is using this kind of thing um
i'm not as familiar with the details but
it is our goal to sort of grow this out
to a larger user base um over the period
of the next few years
i'd say um there are
packages to help um run the experiments
but we primarily designed this so that
we could test our streaming models right
we're on the computational end we want a
platform that lets us
do all this modeling work and then
without touching anybody else's
experimental setup very gently plug in
so that we can have access to the
real-time data streams and continue uh
to work there so we're not actually
writing any software to like run a
microscope automatically
we're just on the data handling end of
things
and visualization a little bit
well it seems like it's the whole brain
of the experimental control i mean i saw
everything everything was there but
anyway um thank you
we interface with labview that does the
control but we're not actively touching
the hardware yeah
so to follow up with that are you guys
doing any kind of image like alignment
or analysis because i i'm kind of
wondering with the python and
concurrency and global
interpreted lock like
if you've hit that wall yet in
computation in which maybe like python
you might be exceeding it's it's it's uh
yeah current currently most of the
the slowest bit of this for these
experiments is this image processing um
and our collaborators um andrea and
eftikios are the ones that have worked
previously on an algorithm called cayman
came in online um which is
a python package with some uh c plus
backend to do
motion correction image stabilization
finding the neurons and extracting out
their their neural activity traces
um so
i think
you know there are additional
computational techniques
there
um
yeah yeah
um hi
um i have a question about the hardware
um
uh requirements for this because um i i
was just wondering like other than you
know uh
brain imaging centers don't typically
like you know
new software on their computers but like
if yours brain imaging center was
cooperative could this be even applied
in human uh
experiments in fmri
like what are what are the
yeah
there's a sort of you know you'd need a
different model for the human fmri and a
different image processing probably but
you just pop in you know a different
image processor in that actor and a
different model in this actor and
everything else would run the same so in
terms of hardware requirements like we
we specifically wanted this to be very
accessible to many neuroscience labs
right so we're running it on a
workstation that's a couple thousand
dollars you know it's you know you have
cpu you need memory you need like a gpu
perhaps if you're gonna use that
um
and in our case for the sort of initial
phase of improv
we put everything that i showed you on a
single computer and just hooked it up
with a 10 gigabit ethernet connection to
the computer that's actually running the
experimental apparatus so we're quite
hands off um and we can do fairly fast
data transfer using like i said 0mq
um and then do all the additional
computation and suggestion for what to
do next in the experiment on our single
improv workstation
but you could definitely
put it on the same computer as the
acquisition system there's nothing
stopping you from doing this you just
need to make sure that you have enough
of the computational resources
ooh that makes me want to go back to
academia that's so cool
all right thank you thank you for the
questions but we do uh run over around
10 minutes already um
so um so and if you don't mind could you
please uh you know put your uh email in
a chat yeah just in case uh you know
people uh can follow up with you on
their questions or more interests
definitely i'd be happy to um you know
set up a zoom or team meeting with
people if they're still interested in
talking
um later yeah thank you thank you
all right um let's proceed because uh we
uh we're short on time um
all right let's uh present our next
speaker uh dave
um
mr dave uh has been uh with neo4j
as an engineer for uh since 2014. in his
role uh dave works with a wide variety
of
consumers from startups to 450 companies
educating uh them on the the value of
the graph graph database
and graph database data science so on so
forth and graphs are you know it being
used right now to power transactional
systems deliver
analytical insights and support data
science and machine learning
and big data problems
dave is based in stanford
virginia
and
he do holds
a master in information system from
george mason university welcome dave
thank you thank you
that was a hard presentation to follow
up so let's see
see how i do
so um thanks for having me
just get squared away
so as you said my name is dave fout
i am
you know a sales engineer at neo4j and
i've been with neo4j since 2014 and have
been working with graph databases
since probably 2011
or so
so tonight um you're probably going
a while something about graph databases
do i really need to learn about yet
another database
so tonight you know hopefully you'll
learn something
try and make this informative
we'll talk about
really just an overview of graph
databases where we use them why we use
them
some information about them we'll dive
into some data science
we'll talk about our python integration
since we should probably talk about
python with this meetup
and we'll do a little demonstration with
some of our data science library
so a lot of ground to cover
feel free to ask questions as you go
along and hopefully at the end of the
night
you'll have a better understanding
of what graph databases are
and really what we see
you know as we've getting into this
connected data is
the connections in the data are as
valuable as the data itself so
understanding
you know how people are connected
what paths they take why they buy things
what they might buy next
how routes
how people trends
go along routes how we can find shortest
paths
how we can make recommendations how we
can fight fraud
you know and how we can understand
knowledge that we've collected within
our organization so building out these
knowledge
networks so the connections in the data
are really what where we see the value
and where organizations see the value
and want to leverage a graph database to
really change how they're doing business
now we see that really
in several of these use cases and i'll
probably spend
more time than you really care about
driving in on use cases but just
understand
where we're seeing companies make the
investment and graph and what value it's
adding
so we see a lot in the drug discovery
understanding
you know how drugs are actually
discovered what that process that they
go
through it might be through crime
detection so putting together a
knowledge graph
putting together activity of people
building out that community of how
people
work together
you know personalization everybody wants
that personalized experience on the
website
so i know
you know our sponsor here is in the
advertising so we see a lot of
trying to understand who that person is
that just hit our website so how can we
build out that community when i see a
new device that's logged into my website
or join the website what do i know about
that ip address to quickly identify
what community they belong to so then i
can start to serve up
personalized product recommendations so
we have customers that are really doing
that identity management and
doing that at web scale
you know especially now that apple's
taking away the tracking we see that
more and more important
um definitely fraud prevention a lot of
work is being done in fraud prevention
you know our traditional network
analysis which has been going on since
the 1990s but
you know building out fraud networks how
do we do how do we understand
what a fraudulent community looks like
how can i connect
you know my
my contact information my email address
my phone number my address
you know to other people and we build
out a community
so when we do have a fraudulent actor
who else might be involved so we see a
lot of
activity done there
you know knowing your customer what is
my 360 view of the customer
compliance
you know and then feeding this into
ai and machine learning so we can
understand what people are buying what's
effective
and i know less and less about ai
machine learning but you know we'll talk
a little bit about that
maybe later tonight but definitely in
some upcoming presentations
and again the graph databases are used
when the connections
are as valuable as the data itself so if
your data doesn't have connections you
don't really care about the connections
you know graph databases are not for you
there's plenty of other technology for
that
but if you want to understand and make
sense of the connections the
connectedness in your data and that's
bringing value to you
then you really want to think about you
know a graph database
so people ask what is a graph so some of
you probably know this so this might be
new if you haven't
we'll just talk about this
you know graphs have been around forever
and we saw this in computer science
classes
but it's really about the relationships
and it started back with leonard
spoiler in the 1700s with this seven
bridges of konigsberg trying to find
that path that went across without
duplicating
and pass
so that was really the foundation and
you can look this up on wikipedia or
other sites to explain it better than i
can but that's really the foundation of
it
so as neo4j
as a company
we invented the label property graph
model that's used today and with us and
with
some of our competitors in the graph
market space so this is
pretty much a common
model that's being used in the industry
today
so i'll just explain this and
i'll make it analogous to
a relational database model so we can
have some contacts
but really in the the circles that we
use are for nodes
so nodes are our things there are
entities or you know objects that we
want to describe so
in this case we have three nodes two of
them happen to be people
and one is a car
so we
we think about these objects that we
want to model out in our data model
nodes would be
analogous to
to actually to our
rows in the database
and we use labels so we group labels to
classify our nodes in the graph
so in this case we have a person label
on this guy on the left we have a person
label on and over here on the right and
we've classified this red node as a car
and those are analogous to your tables
so we want to group nodes we want to be
able to
identify person nodes or maybe a car
node
and then relationships which are the
bread and butter the you know the
important part about the graph
really tell how these nodes are related
so
you know how is dan
related to ann
dan is married to ann
dan lives with anne that's a good thing
and owns a car
you know dan drives the car that ann
owns
so the relationships tell us how the
nodes are related
um
they have a type
so that's drives owns mary2 lives with
they have a direction so it's always
from a node to a node
from an o to a node
and they just give us that context how
does this make sense what does this
graph make sense
and then we have properties so those are
key value pairs
they're attributes that we can apply to
the node
or to the relationship
and just as you would in a relational
database have columns in your table
let's say
i have a name i have a born i have a
twitter property
my car i have a brand model a location
like long
i have an attribute on the drive since
they just give us more context about the
graph
and the nice thing about this is i could
show this to my wife who's not technical
and she would quickly understand it so
as we
in our in my role as i talk to business
analysts or to
people that make decisions this is
pretty easy to understand
you know to understand the context of
our data to understand
why these are related why it's important
and what we're trying to
portray
or give context to the end user
so this is a labeled property graph
model it's different than rdf i'm not
going to go down that
rabbit hole today
but neo4j and other
graph databases use the property graph
model
this is just a different view of it it
is our key structure underpinning
the graph and again
you know we have an employee here as a
node which has some properties their
name value pairs that we store
we can search on those we can look those
up we can add those dynamically
we have the relationships that tell us
the con context those are the verbs
you know the company is located in a
city
company as a ceo of amy peters
she started on january 20th 2008. so
again
just context about a property graph
showing us how we can build these out
and if you any questions please
please speak up please ask questions
so why would we use
you know a graph database
you know what are the things that make
sense when would we use it
um when we want to store data
relationships natively so neo4j and some
of the other competitors
we'll store these natively so we're not
doing join tables we're not building
relationship joins we're actually
connecting the data as we write it
so once we find the nodes we can
traverse quickly
down a long number of hops or
connections to find the data that we
that we need
the data natively is a graph
we think about it as a graph it's not
just
you know a big document that we want to
store it's not just purely
transactions or really not
densely connected data
we want to use that relationship
information to transform our business we
want to know again who's in this
community
is this person fraudulent a fraudulent
actor
what's the shortest path to get my
delivery from chicago to houston in the
next three days all these type of things
uh transform the business
and then it allows us
to dynamically change the model adjust
the model add new relationships add new
node types on the fly
a lot more flexible
so again you know we can argue about
this
you know in the relational databases do
their job well for what they're designed
for
what we've generally seen
in my experience is
as we decide to
go down more and more traversals or
build out deeper traversals where we
don't know how far down they they'll go
or how far the traversal is um the
relational database performance degrades
just because the number of joins we have
to do
self joins it's a lot more complex to
write
you know if you're doing one or two
joins
you know those are still really good and
i wouldn't argue against using a
relational database but
6 7 30 40
hops
you know neo4j
other competitors in our space can
handle that quickly
and the ability for us to change that
design and new data and new
relationships on the fly
is really important as you're
as you're working through the graph so
you're not dropping tables copying
tables
et cetera et cetera you know relational
databases have their place graph
databases have their place
right tool for the right job
um this is a little dated so i'm sure
some of the other competitors have
probably added in
different join logic
but some of them
you know
do these joins in the application
not everyone has acid support for
transactions so that might be something
of importance
you know even if you're in
like elastic you're trying to join keys
on the fly it's just
not the optimal solution these databases
have their place they have their role
again if you're looking at relationships
and making sense of that
you'll look at a graph database for that
all right
again just a summary here um
i'll kind of i'm just going to skip
through that but
you know our the language that we use
very simple to write very easy to use
won't dig in too much of that
and again as we do this
whiteboard friendly pretty easy to model
i wouldn't say it's bulletproof
we definitely do need to think about
your data modeling the types of queries
that you want to use
but a lot of times when we go on site
it's really easy to take this conceptual
model
draw these circles draw these
connections on the whiteboard
or on in powerpoint or some other tool
and build your logical model that you
can then load data in and start to write
queries so
so again like in this case acme is a
company kayla is a ceo
you know there's some organizations
it's a little bit dated the device so we
can see run these relationships we can
take this whiteboard model
modify it
iterate over it change it on the fly and
then apply it to
to our business
so you may ask you know what are these
graph shape problems what should i when
should i think about using a graph
database when does it make sense for
that
you know in this case we have
no customer buying t-shirt
another customer buying a t-shirt
we might want to understand
you know how similar are those customers
can we identify some similarities
you know people that bought product x
might buy product y so let's make a
recommendation about that
on a website you know what
what are the common paths that they're
taking so what might be the next best
action
you know what are common paths that
people take
fraud detection is understanding the
relationships are there
can we build communities based off of
shared identifiers to understand how big
that fraudulent community is or the
potential for fraud
identity resolution
you know if i have different names that
are living at the same address using the
same phone number but it might be
misspelled
i can leverage the graph to help with
that identity resolution so
you know if there's relationships that
make sense
we should probably think about a graph
um other kind of self-referencing so
hierarchies
we might see this in a multi-level
marketing
you know where you build out a hierarchy
you might see it in your organizational
chart who manages whom
friend of friends
so again some organizational hierarchy
we see this also in
network topology where you see
you know network topology is a graph
because of the connectedness
that's a good use case as well is it as
well as data lineage how does data move
through an organization
a lot of companies will use a graph to
identify how data moves through an
organization
um yeah varying or unknown depth we see
this in
you know network management
moving things through
you know like a manufacturing how does
things move through a plan
you know what where are we seeing delays
and processing all these types of chains
excellent use cases
and then routes so
you know what's the shortest path what's
a
how do we do infrastructure
you know what's the optimal path to get
a product from point a to point z within
a certain time period
so lots of different routes and lots of
different paths
so just to show you the other one that's
really common
is knowledge graphs
so i just want to show you today or this
week going on there's
you know the knowledge graph conference
in new york so
just to show you different use cases and
what people are thinking about so
here's some of our
you know star dog is a knowledge graph
company they're doing work
another
competitor onto text but
you know ubs financial services
building a knowledge graph on connecting
banks data
lexus nexus another company doing graphs
um
neo4j and
graphs there
accenture on clinical trials and
reasoning very interesting
let's see what else
oracle doing graph queries
a customer 360 knowledge graph into it
for financial tech
let's see if there's anything else
google with some neural networks
tomorrow let's just look
you know ibm research how do we do
knowledge graph construction from tech
so
how can i do that david meza neo4j
you know nasa build a knowledge graph
that's helped them get to mars faster
just by understanding lessons learned
and the reason i want to show you this
is
you know graphs are becoming more and
more mainstream it's not a niche
thing that
you know was kind of a curiosity 10
years ago it's more and more mainstream
microsoft
machine learning models
snapchat real time inference
here's cap gemini morgan stanley
bbc graph project so you see graphs are
more and more here's drug discovery for
knowledge graphs
and just
see if there's anything else on
harvard medical school this will be
friday bloomberg
you just see the depth of different
companies fidelity for data analytics
business decisions
and you see a lot of the different
companies out there so i just want to
point out that you know graphs are no
longer this niche
products they're definitely mainstream
something you should be aware of maybe
it's not your day-to-day job but
something to be aware of
but again just a wide variety everything
from chat bots to data lineage to fraud
risk assessment
logistics promotions pricing
the list goes on and on and on
and again i think the common thing here
is these all are about
relationships between
between
individuals so
we saw that in panama and paradise
papers that are being used now to
understand the russian oligarchy and how
they're who they're connected to where
their money lives
ownership money laundering fraud
definitely cyber security is a lot of
interest
lessons learned
a lot of interest in drug discovery
research in the sciences
supply chain network and i t
so tons of different use cases tons of
different usage
so graph database you know a traditional
database
you know not probably not all that
exciting because it's still you know how
do you sell a database you sell it to
solve business problems
so
probably about three years ago
neo4j
started focusing on graph data science
so
there was some work done in
you know the hadoop world with different
graphics and other libraries
we know that
companies want
to make sense of the data they want to
do graph data science
how do you figure out which open source
tool is there which products available
so neo4j made a corporate decision to
invest engineering resources into what
we call the graph data science library
and what we've done is we have 50 plus
graph algorithms in neo4j that can
leverage
you know the relationships in neo4j and
in the graph database to make sense of
your data so
you know in our community detection and
our fraud we may have a database that
has
you know a person that has a credit card
a phone number and address
and an email address and we may share
those so we may decide that we want to
do a luvine or you know weekly connected
components
against that graph
and then write out a component id so we
can understand how are things connected
so i can do that with the graph i can do
it with these algorithms that are
provided by neo4j tested by neo4j run at
scale by neo4j
and make sure that this works
and we have people that are doing
routing that have
have paths defined in neo4j between
waypoints so we can do you know a
shortest pair
a dexter pair or a weighted path to find
the optimal path from point a to point z
and with sub-second response time
maybe it's a page rank or an article
rank we're doing link production
seeing a lot more interest in embeddings
with fast rp or graph sage so
a lot of work being done in these graph
algorithms work that we continually do
to help our customers and to help the
community make sense of that and we'll
do a little bit of a demonstration here
shortly on this
so how this works in neo4j
is we take our native graph store
we move this into an in-memory
a mathematical representation
we run these algorithms on that
in-memory
representation so it's fast
we can write back to the graph we can
mutate those in memory and use those
results maybe that page rank score that
centrality score to feed that into
another algorithm
and build these
data science pipelines in memory and
then write results back out or feed
those into your machine learning
pipeline so
we will have
i think mark's working on setting up a
more detailed
discussion by our chief data science
alicia frame on this later this year
no
look at that a double slide
and really why is this important just
because those relationships
just give us so much more information
they just
add value into your machine learning
models into our data science so we make
make sense out of those relationships
and feed the data into
into that
dave
yes
um this is mark i um
since we're we're a data science
community um i think most people
who've been around for a while would uh
be familiar with the term word to vec
and
um
one of the things that i've seen from
the graphic algorithms is a node to vec
um
is
is that correct in the uh
in the 50 graph algorithms is is
producing a no defect
structure
um yeah it should be in the embeddings
but
okay
yeah there's a node to back so
we've documented all of these algorithms
and
i'll talk about how you can get started
with this um
you know other there's other
vendors in the graph data space that
have similar algorithms
you can use
for better or for worse but yeah there
is a node devec
we do a pretty good job on this
algorithm and our documentation
we talk about how it's actually used
give some code samples and some results
so
and the different embeddings
so generally we'll use a lot of these
node embeddings then to feed into
machine learning so we'll calculate a
lot of these
and then feed those into some machine
learning pipeline
did that help mark
mark you're on mute again
yes thank you all right
cool so i got just a couple more slides
here and then we'll do some
demonstration
so again
just to show you
so there's this company out here or this
website that does db engines and it just
really ranks
um
you know based on
i know
linkedin jobs
social media posts
blog posts
other really things just the most
popular databases so
oracle's at the top mysql microsoft kind
of your traditional
ones we kind of pride ourselves that
we're not 19th in the most popular
database category
neo4j
in the graph space just
to be transparent you know we do have 20
i picked the top 20 here
the neo4j
cosmos is kind of this i don't know
hybrid thing
these multi-modal show up
murango db is pretty good
amazon neptune obviously they're a
competitor to us so
you can get started with amazon neptune
you can use that
we have a hybrid rdf sql underlying
janus graph that one is pretty much dead
tiger graph is our probably one of our
most popular competitors
um they're doing a lot of marketing they
have a graph data science
definitely they're definitely focused on
the analytic side
and then the rest of these really end up
being more
i don't know i i would say more niche
companies we don't
really see those being used a lot by you
know your fortune 500 or other
corporations so
in the graph data space it will usually
be neo4j summarango neptune some
microsoft
tiger graph
maybe a little bit of d graph
and then people will just fall back to i
can do this in postgres or i can
i'll just brute force it i don't need a
graph database so
you know those are the competitors
and the score just kind of shows you
neo4j being around being
the leader kind of the gap that we have
but you know we definitely don't rest on
our laurels and continue to improve
and so for the python
you know we know that we have a lot of
people that use python so we do have
this
language driver so we write our own
drivers
that we'll talk to the graph engine
through
through our native cipher language over
a binary
protocol or through http so
we do use the python
there are other
out of the box drivers
since this is python we'll focus on that
and then there are some documentation
for that so
before we jump to the demo
you know if you want to get started on
the database so
there's several ways to actually use
neo4j um i'm sure there are there are
other ways for competitors
so feel free to take a look at those
we do have a cloud instance called
auradb so it's our database as a service
that runs in the cloud
you can get started with that for free
it's a small amount of nodes and small
amount of edges i think it's maybe 50
000
but if you don't want to install
anything on your laptop or on your
network you can run
or a db and then in the cloud
and then you can if you decide you want
to pay more you want to run it on
enterprise we have other offerings
that might be the last slide
um
let's go to the next one
so we have there's a couple other
options so let's see if i can
so neo4j desktop will actually download
a full copy of neo4j enterprise edition
plus a couple of our utilities
you can include the graph data science
library it gets downloaded to your
desktop as a single user
fully licensed piece of software so if
you can download to your laptop
you can do that
we have some predefined
let me see
we have neo4j sandbox so if you just
want to get experiment with neo4j
understand what's going on
this is like a three day online you just
enter in your email and get added to our
email distribution list
but you can launch a free sandbox we
have different scenarios in there
so maybe you want to look at just our
movies database or network and i.t
paradise papers so you can get started
with neo4j that way as well
um
i think that's all
the ways that we want to get started
so let me just close a few things out
here
so we're going to use
just this little database here so i'm
going to this is our neo4j browser we
see that
you know we're going to build this
through python but
we just have
some dummy you know web page links
so we have nodes that are connected via
links to each other so our labels are on
the side our links are on the side
and i'm going to
try and run this
through a python notebook just to show
you how this works
so let's get rid of that
um
so we also have the graph data science
as a service so
you know you can download this
onto your laptop and include the graph
data science library
but if you want to
run it in the cloud
it does cost some money so just to
be transparent
somewhere in here i had the pricing
yeah not there
oh it's a few dollars a day so
i don't know it's not free
so it's one way of getting started so
we'll walk through this notebook
just to show you so
because we don't we find that
in the past we've made python developers
become database gurus and understanding
how to load data in
we've written our own graph data science
python
library so we're going to just import
this
it's
going to make things easier so let me
see if i can
so you know it's got a lot of algorithms
we have this library and it just helps
us interact with the database and run
these different algorithms so that's
really what we're going to use it helps
us with data frames and other things
that python data scientists know
about a million things about
so i'm just going to actually create a
connection into my database
but
i don't know how to do that
all right
and we've got you know we're running
graph data science version 2.0.3 so
we've connected to
this database here that's running up on
google cloud
and
now we're actually going to run some
ciphers so we're going to create that
graph that i destroyed so we're going to
create some
pages we're going to create some links
with some weights between them
and if we go back to our graph
you know we're back to what we had
before so so we have these pages we have
these links
so now what we're going to do is we're
going to actually project this you know
graph
dave to interrupt you um so can you uh
show us how you create the graph again
okay yeah so
we're using our cypher language so
these are just a bunch of statements
that say we're going to create a node
just copy this
and how we do it we just say
we're going to create a
a no we'll give it a variable
we'll add a label
and then we're going to use
that name we'll add some properties
and then once this refreshes
i don't know this browser acts weird
sometimes
so that's how we would do it i mean this
is really simple because it's only eight
nodes uh but now we should have a person
node here so let me just refresh this
grab the password
you know there's probably 20 different
ways to get data into
neo4j
as soon as this comes back
it'll be there
yeah so we have my person know that i've
created
and we have the age and the name
so as we do this in this notebook
you know we're creating a page we're
going to give it a variable home
about they all have names and then here
we say
home this node here
has a links relationship to the about
page and
the property weight is a value of 0.2
so we're persisting this data in the
graph
inside of the database inside of the
neo4j database so this is persisted data
at the moment
that's in the graph
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to say i want to create an
in-memory graph called example dash
graph i'm going to use the page find all
the page nodes
find all the links nodes and we're going
to use this relationship properties
so we're going to take that
database graph and bring it into memory
so we can operate on it with some of our
graph data science libraries
so if we run this
we have a node projection
we have a graph name called example
graph
there's eight no's and fourteen
relationships
and this is how we normally we'll run
the graph data science
to bring this into memory and then we
can do different algorithms maybe we
would do the
centrality score the
page rank or the other data science
libraries on this
so we'll just list it out
it's pretty small it's only using a
couple megabytes of memory
so we can we do a lot of data
compression we make this small in memory
we're going to run it
and then we're actually going to
run our graph data science page rank get
some statistics on it we'll do 20
iterations
with a damping factor of 0.85
so again i don't have to find a python
library or another library to figure out
page rank or write my own page rank
algorithm
so we will run this
so i just ran it to get some statistics
on it
it'll tell me the centrality
distribution
how long it took it took 67 milliseconds
to compute
our configuration
so we're going to stream that out get
some results back
so node id 0 has a page rank score of
3.2
1.05 for 1 2. so we've run a page rank
across this tiny tiny graph and got some
results back
so then in our next step we want to
actually write this back to
the database so we want to persist this
in our database
and we're going to call this pagerank
score
so we're going to take the results of
that attach it back to
each one of these pages so we'll just
click on it we have site b
we have home they have no property
called page rank score
so let's run this
and we get you know home has 3.25 so
if we come back and we rerun this
now we have a pagerank score written
back persisted into the graph so we can
do other analysis or other data science
on this type of information so we may
take this pagerank score and now extract
this information and feed that into our
machine learning pipeline or some
downstream
process that can make use of that
pagerank score
you know if it was like no devac where
we add
vectors in the we could pass those on
down as well
so
you know trying to make this easy for a
data scientist
to interact with
the graph database to run these graph
algorithms
without understanding you know all the
ins and outs of the in how do we do this
with the database so it's kind of a
focus for us to make it easier for
python graph data scientists to do this
we're going to drop the in-memory graph
so we removed it from memory so there is
no more in-memory graph that we can run
correct data science on so we free up
that memory
and
our little
gds experiment is finished and we can go
grab a cup of coffee or
go grab something to eat because our
data science piece is done
hey dave can i ask you a quick question
yeah absolutely
um
uh as a data scientist uh you know we
always deal with uh tabular datas right
those uh columns and rows
um
if i really have uh the opportunity i
would love to transform those tabular
data into graph data
formats right so we have to
uh
you know
like you showed us uh in the uh you know
jupiter notebook create
a link or person
uh so we have to
do this kind of thing for every single
tabular data table
yeah so that's a good question on data
loading so
um
so let's just create like
i'm just going to create a little simple
model here
so let's just do like
person
and i know let's say
so let's say i have a table a person i
have an email table
and then i have a join table so we have
some
you know we can write python that would
basically you know read from that table
uh
construct that statement and process
those in large batches
we have
we have what we call load csv so if you
have that data in a delimited format we
can read that in and create that
from a local
system so
um
you know in the previous presentation
they talked about
arrow piero
so we're actually baking that into the
graph data science library because
you know we want to bring make that
easier to bring data in and out i mean
pi arrow is phenomenal at moving data in
and out of databases we have spark
connectors
you know there's a hundred
i don't know as many
ways you can bring data in
we could probably do it so
you know so there are programmatic ways
that we would do this
you know you're not going to take a
million rows and
and write you know create x create y
you're going to say connect to the
database
transform it to
transform all load all the person nodes
load all the email nodes and then let's
join those on you know find the person
find an email and create that
relationship
yeah this is really uh good news because
uh
um
for local
load csv for example um
that's um so are you saying
uh cypher languages
you're using cipher uh as native
language right yeah yeah
so
so are you saying the
neo4j uh platform when you call load csv
it will uh
automatically identify
which is the uh
note which is the property and which is
the link we don't have to worry about
that
yeah let me actually just copy like that
let me bring this into
it's not magic um
well dave is doing that let me let me
make a comment it's my intention that
20 2022 and 2023 are going to be
a little graph database centric
uh heavy
and uh one of the sessions that i
thought would be very useful is all the
different ways that you can
get data into
a graph a graph database
so we we've seen cypher that that will
get it in
dave has just shown load csv uh there's
an import statement the apoc
libraries have have something so there's
there's a variety a variety of uh
powerful fast
uh import mechanisms
if you need them
and that i want that to be one of the
uh
presentations um
just concentrating on getting data in
and another one concentrating on getting
data out but that's my goal and if you
if you think differently let me know
yeah so i just thanks mark appreciate
that so just this is just really simple
so this is
from somebody else so
you know we have a file that's policy to
customer so in that
in that csv file there's a column that's
called customer id
just there's this policy
there's another role called policy id so
the merge you know this is just neo4j
specific intact
hey dave i think we're still seeing
chrome if you're typing somewhere else
oh i'm sorry
all right
you might have to restart the share to
get a new different window in
oh yeah thanks
all right
that's cool there you go that looks good
yeah so in this case we're
you know we just have a simple
csv and that csv may look like
so one you know one two
two three
so we're going to say you know what this
statement does is it'll read this
csv file and it says
create a node with the label customer
the merge will do an upsert
you know find
me a node with the label customer with a
property customer id of one
if that does not exist created otherwise
let's use that node so we don't have
duplicates
same for the policy i have a policy id
of one
and then the line four says you know
create a relationship called has policy
from from the customer node to the
policy node
so this works
for
probably about
i don't know up to a million rows so if
you have
you know a million rows load csv is
pretty easy
as long as we can get to it
you know either locally through the file
it could be through
http a website you know a url that you
can access
so that's kind of like the lowest common
denominator
we build a neat a new tool to help you
with that
probably something to demo but then you
know you can write custom python to do
processing we have
there's tools
that are available
spark
connector yada yada
java you know all the different drivers
etc etc kafka you know all these
different ways of
allowing us to connect to the data
so let me just
let me kill
one
thing sorry
not a teams expert here
so again this is really um
meant to be used so
you know there'll be a new release of
if we go to
you know if you if you're a python
developer and a graph data science
you know
we have this library tiger graph has
their own it's a little
my opinion a little harder to use
because you have to
do a lot more code writing
i think the other some of the other
vendors have it as well
you know but this is a library you can
install
you can run it open source so
you know it will limit on a couple
things
and it'll limit you to four cpus you
won't get everything but
you know you can definitely experiment
with
your different graph algorithms
we're constantly working on these moving
these
beta algorithms more into production
quality
constantly improving the product
constantly trying to run it at scale so
we know
you know data is getting larger
customers want to run larger and larger
volumes
you know even if you're a researcher
you know it's still a great product to
use it's a great tool to
you know to make sense of your connected
data
and even if you just go to the
documentation and see what's available
you know i think it's pretty interesting
this is great thank you dave uh do you
mind
maybe share this online documentation in
a chat
yeah absolutely
so mark are you are you saying we uh
we can have more uh
uh presentations with regards to uh you
know uh
variety of ways how to
uh import the data and how to create a
graph database those kind of
presentations coming in
yes so uh my my idea
and i've i sent an email to the
oh the training person elaine at neo4j
just to ask her if i'm on track or or
off off off base on on this idea but to
have
a session or a presentation that's
primarily getting data into
a graph database
a session would and there's a variety of
things and then ways of getting uh data
out of a graph database and there's
primarily two for that one is going to
be cipher
or this is open cipher now
neo4j was kind enough to
put their query language into the open
source community and then
they've got a way of
taking graphql
and converting that internally into
cipher so that you could
you you could and dave correct me if i'm
wrong once again correct me if i'm wrong
um
that that you could take an application
uh that was
uh trying to get try to use graph or was
using graphql as the query language and
um
kind of put something between that those
calls and neo4j and you'd get the
the value or the speed and performance
of a cipher
query
um so follow up but we do you know we do
have a graphql
um
connector
you know interface so you can write
graphql so you know graphql is just the
standard
to basically build an api against any
database so there's graphqls for every
database in our top 20 list
so it's not graph specific or neo4j
specific you can do graphql the [ __ ] to
oracle to you know postgres so but there
is a graphql so you can write that json
type queries against neo4j
if you're trying to build a
you know a rest endpoint
but again just as there's different ways
to get in data there's a myriad of ways
to get data out so
yeah
and
uh john lay you asked about um rel you
know tables table for table formats rows
and columns
neo4j does have the ability to output
into rows and co into row and column
format
if you have to
consume that consume the output of the
query the graph query in
something that doesn't that doesn't
speak
you know circles circles and arrows
yes um yeah that that that's uh that's
really good news um
i don't necessarily right not everybody
cares that
you know not everybody cares about the
pretty pictures
right so maybe you just want to know
you know give me a fraud score for this
person i got a new insurance claim
what's the likelihood that this person's
fraudulent or
you know this person's transaction we
see this a lot you know
you know is this a fraudulent
transaction give me a score back so i
don't really care about the path or the
connectedness i just
need a value or
you know an api end-to-end api so
you know it's a database so we can make
it do whatever you need it to do
yeah i do care pretty pictures
dave yeah
all but then you know when you have to
put it into action
yeah cool
um anyone had any other questions for
dave
yeah dave i'm curious about um
how how well this scales to
big data distributed systems
yeah i mean that's definitely
something we're working on and we
continue to work on so i know
no meredith who's probably kind of in
your space
he always used it in the billions i
think they're probably at the 8 billion
identifiers so they definitely use it
for
identifying those components that's
probably
you know right now
you know
with hardware and how we handle things
it's probably about that scale and we
have some data scientists at larger
um it depends if you don't need that
real time or you're doing more data
science type work
that makes sense you know we're doing
some things with some distributed
um
distributed querying so
you know i think
between us and tiger graph you'll see
different marketing and different spin
on who can get bigger the faster so
you know definitely read between the
lines ask questions if you're if you're
thinking about those are probably your
two biggest players as far as at scale
right now
um
and doing it correctly
you know i think there's some dispute on
you know everybody publishes metrics and
benchmarks so you always take those with
a grain of salt but
you know we've been able to get into the
tens of billions of nodes and
tens of billions of relationships and
we're running like meredith is running
those weekly connected components in
memory on
probably a 512 gigabyte memory machine
so
yeah oh you know we're doing some work
with some of our other
larger scale so that's really why we
invested we're doing a lot of work with
pi arrow we just saw
you know we're doing some work now where
we can take data out of like bigquery or
feed it directly into the in-memory
graph and then because
you know we don't always necessarily
need that persistent storage so i may
want to run an experiment do some
analysis
get my results throw it away start over
so
let's work that i don't know i would say
we're not
there yet i mean we definitely need some
work around the product to get there but
you know it's
it's a harder problem for us to solve
because you know when you get at that
scale you're using a lot of hardware
resources and then yeah i'm sure like
you guys you don't want to buy
you're not going to buy one or spin up a
one terabyte memory google cloud machine
for every data scientist you want to
think about costs and yep just work
across my data science team do i really
need 50 vms for 50 data scientists can
you fix that so those are some of the
areas that we're trying to figure out
and trying to make work as we
as we interact
yeah another maybe more
fundamental question just get a better
grasp on it you know i feel like with
the
relational database my mental picture of
how data gets stored at you know the
most granular level is something like a
csv file
i think that's really a tangible
connection
for a graph database does that look more
like a json or how how do you actually
handle data on disk
yeah let me see if i can find that
diagram
yeah ted
they have a conference every year the
the graph connect conference every year
in the summer and uh the sessions are on
uh their youtube channel the neo4j
youtube channel
somebody last summer
just kept multiplying the number of
nodes by 10 and kept getting
you know
below triple digit millisecond response
on their queries and i was like holy
crap
that's fast
yeah let me just share this yeah it
seems like your
power to scale really doesn't fit my
intuition because it's it's so efficient
for some of these calculations yeah so
we kind of pay that price so
this hasn't changed this will change
probably
in our next release you know later this
year but
well what they decided to do back is
you know they did try this on i think
postgres
probably in like 2009 2010 and it didn't
work
so basically everything's a fixed length
record so the note is like a fixed
length of
15 bytes i think and a relationship is
31 bytes and a properties some other
number of bytes
so we store the node and it has like
different
you know it has this id it has a couple
types
and then the relationship has an id
an internal idv track it has the start
node id the endnote id and then these
keys attached to it
and then you know these have the
relationship so each relationship type
we know the start id and the end id
so we just say if we can find the start
node
through either an index lookup
or some way to get to the start node
then we can just find oh i want to know
the nose relationship oh let's
here's the first in-memory id
then we just follow these pointers
here's the next and then we just kind of
hop between pointers back and forth
so we're doing we're not doing joins at
run time we're doing joins on creation
so
this number three joins on creation is
really
kind of the bottleneck that we hit then
so we got to pay the price somewhere
and since we're asset compliant
you know we pay that price on these
joints so we would actually
you know nodes are if i just write nodes
i can write those really fast all day
long
it's when we get into relationships
where i have to lock one node lock
another node and then we have to get
kind of creative on how we create
relationships so
that's why we kind of you know when we
talk about problems like
with earlier talk on the volume of data
yeah we may not always be able to in
ingest that volume of data so we would
think you know what is a proper data
store for this and what's a proper data
scheme before that
yeah and then in terms of like
flexibility and expandability
um are there if you have to add a new
type of node or a new type of
relationship
i imagine some of that you can just add
in incrementally here and other other
varieties you might have to recalculate
these relationships is that
that accurate yeah so like you know and
we can just add like a new
you know i can add dynamically add these
which you know we're in the nosql so
you know you have the ability to add
these but you also have the ability to
screw things up as well just very
easily you know with great
flexibility is great power
so really for us it's then
you know so we can basically like i
don't know
yeah we can dynamically add a new label
like i don't know
you know but this is in a transactional
state so
you know we would
have to do some logic in there you know
like if we had 10 million students i
don't want to do that in one big
transaction because it goes into heat
and it's pretty easy to crash
so we would do that in like batches of
50 000 so you know it's kind of
we have a library that's called apoc
that's kind of everything that didn't
get into the core product as workarounds
and we're kind of building some of that
into the later releases of cipher to
help with that but
yeah send all right how do i do this
because now it's
you know a transactional state i don't i
need to do it smartly and
do it that way
so you can do it it's just
you know it's not just hey just write a
query
you know change a million oh [ __ ] i ran
out of
memory well thank you
yeah absolutely
all right uh thank you dave for uh the
wonderful
yeah one for presentation of the
insightful
demo very very insightful thank you
um
we're on time for our
lightning talks
um
okay um
so uh anyone want to
share
any um
little experiments you want to share
with everybody today
mark do we have the uh speaker for
lining talk today
oh well uh somebody somebody posted a
comment in the meetup page and said that
they wanted to do a um
a lightning talk but
if if you're
whoever you are if you're here speak up
unmute yourself and
you're you're welcome to
to do a presentation
i see uh the p
peter
vetoes
is people here
peter's not here